[Music]
this wreath is on fire today
you WKMG
the Dutch station
you
here we go
it's the Lord's name on the front this
Sunday August 7th it's a beautiful day
to be alive I'm home I want to thank all
the people that came out to the Cherokee
Casino last night in Oklahoma you
[ __ ] rocked the house last
night your savages they came in from
Tulsa your good week Tuesday night uh
but the [ __ ] Saturday [ __ ]
densification [ __ ] them be
understanding either be there or be
square [ __ ] but I [ __ ] together
you wrote your goals yeah you [ __ ]
nah whatever the [ __ ] you care [ __ ]
milkshake
oh I love it guys this is it this is my
[ __ ] world right here everything else
is background [ __ ] music I love
smoking this reefing with you
[ __ ] and just sharing this
little moment this is a beautiful thing
what we do not a lot of people even have
to [ __ ] not even the [ __ ] mind to
do this this is as simple as can be the
simplicity a bunch of [ __ ] savages
just gettin ritha together sharing the
thought you telling me to go [ __ ] myself
I love it wels world can this happen I'm
saying
nice nice nice I love it I love it
listen you do what you do when are you
busy during the week Monday through
Friday you got lies you got kids but on
Sundays you gotta hit this magic pipe
just like the [ __ ] Indians that you
gotta hit this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah I
love just the ability in the foot twenty
years you think when I was buying weed
and [ __ ] Harlem under the 70-acre
dance event do you think that I was
sitting in my car going someday I'm
gonna be able to get high with all my
[ __ ] goombah simultaneous now my
[ __ ] phone are you getting me a one
anyway
we're here with we write your goals it's
gonna be a good week the rest is up to
you maybe you could make it good and you
can make it bad yourself
grab your balls suck [ __ ] get fumed
up for the week and get out there stamp
[ __ ] that's it it's your world
we're just visiting with the thug
young-sam
hmm I just had a little [ __ ] protein
shake the book back the [ __ ] - Benito's
Milo's back until after I finish this
paper little couple CBeebies under the
tongue can take care of [ __ ] jetlag
and everything I'm gonna wash my [ __ ]
the kids my wife and the baby should be
here couple [ __ ] 1 o'clock and that's
it the rest I got my [ __ ] plan
outlines for the week you know that's
how you [ __ ] do it [ __ ] I got
my plan I'm gonna know every minute
where I'm gonna be the next [ __ ]
three days till Thursday who does that
[ __ ] only an [ __ ] like me I got out
early and I get back in early before
anybody sees me [ __ ] making a move
but Joey what's it the chitter chatter
if we're gonna sit here you gonna waste
my [ __ ] phone at least let's do a
couple pointers for Jerry's kids done I
was way ahead of ya he's just playing
your [ __ ] head just to see what you
want to do young Sam I don't want to
come off like the [ __ ] hit him you
know when I was a kid I used to stay out
with my friends at North Bergen and we
do blow you know everybody was always
seven of us every chip and then jumping
up and down the next day it was called
as Koko that kept me out that
[ __ ] kept me out really that was
there must have been somebody else
imaginary snorting [ __ ] blow next to
me or they blamed it on me [ __ ]
so that's it nice bloody SAP everybody's
[ __ ] you know doing that thing cuz
that's the most important I'm here to
keep your [ __ ] powder dry down while
you lose your mind that's the most
important they're gonna keep your powder
dry whatever it does if it means you put
adobo or PS once a week that's what it
takes you know what I gotta go I ain't
gonna go find you anyway what so I'm
stone to the guilt I'm gonna wash my
[ __ ] and wait for my family to come
home I got some right to do maybe a
podcast maybe a little [ __ ] a little
resting and that's it I only slept three
hours last night I took a little siesta
on the flight you know you know how good
you sleep with a face I got a [ __ ]
nightmare going straight anyway I love
you [ __ ] have a good day with
your families
remember this is it Sunday's the day you
put your ball this is what I'm gonna do
lay it down
[ __ ] Anthony Robbins I ain't walking on
coals no more stay black